In the United States,
for example,
if we take census numbers and if we
assume that the homes,
the households in the US are going to
become a little smaller such as Germany
today,
the United States will have to build 74
million new homes or the next 40 years,
74 million.
This is more than the United Kingdom.
France,
Canada,
and Australia put together has today in
pencil halls.
This is not China,
this is the United States,
but now the question is how out of the
city going to grow?
Everybody agrees today that low density
suburbs,
which is the characteristic urban net
structure,
the United States is not convenient for
quality of life,
our environment,
but also most Americans don't want to
live in Manhattan either.
They don't want to live in high rises,
facing a narrow sidewalk on a street
full of cars,
which is dangerous where people may get
killed,
which is noisy.
So the question is we need to build 74
million new homes in the United States
and whatever it is done in the United
States would have a huge influence in
the rest of the world.
How are they see this going to be
billed,
so why not think of an American new
American safety with which is dense with
thousands of miles of greenways and
pedestrian only wrote criss crossing in
a city which would be offer density with
offering the same things that people
seek in the suburbs such as green and
safe spaces for children to ride
bicycles.
I radically different design because
clearly we are talking about technology.
What do we have in suburbs or downtown?
Neither one of those works,
so we clearly need to think about
different urban model,
but the second question is not only how,
but where are they see this going to be
up in the United States.
Clearly you should not be billed beyond
the existing suburbs far away beyond the
exiting sober.
So where is,
where are these 74 million homes to be
built?
I would say the obvious answer would be
to build demolishing,
demolishing thousands,
tens of thousands of hectors.
I'll make 16 sobers,
which where were located?
Why is the United States so important?
Because this has been an enormous
influence on what is to happen all over
the world and I see it,
I see these only means to our way of
life.
So designing a CD will reality signing
ways of life,
whatever
we're to do,
or the next 40 or 50 years in developing
countries will determine the word
sustainability,
quality of life and happiness for
millions.
I am absolutely convinced that radically
not designs a very different cities are
possible.
They are very simple.
They are politically very difficult,
but they could lead us to have cities
which are much more sustainable,
where people will live much happier
lives.